my name is Elizabeth Hillman and my
research involves developing new imaging
methods microscopy methods and optical
techniques using lasers and light to
image the living brain and to understand
the way that the brain functions and the
way that the brain regulates its blood
flow we took very high-speed camera
images of the blood vessels on the
surface of the brain and when we did a
stimulus we were able to actually watch
the blood vessels dilate really really
high speeds and when we did that we saw
this sort of spreading of the dilation
of those vessels and that's something
that people hadn't really seen before
because no one had imaged as fast as we
managed to image what we found is
basically that there's this layer of
cells on the inside of blood vessels
called the endothelium which nobody had
really looked at in great detail in the
brain before but we found that it's
capable of actually sending signals
propagating signals and that this
propagation of signals is a really
important component of increasing blood
flow in the brain so this gives us new
insight into how this blood flow
regulation is is working at a sort of
mechanistic level it's also really
important because nobody thought that
this process was taking place in the
brain even though it's known to take
place everywhere else in the body and
this provides a new link to other
diseases in the rest of the body that we
know affect these endothelial cells but
nobody's really thought about the
possibility that they tie into the brain
the reason why so many people are
interested in this blood flow response
is because it's the basis of the signal
that you measure there in functional MRI
and so functional MRI is this technique
that you can use to image the brains of
humans and we'll give you these
beautiful maps where you see this big
bright red blob that says right this is
where the activation is happening what
that MRI machine is actually measuring a
change in the amount of deoxyhemoglobin
the brain so it actually measures a
change in the blood not in the neurons
and people have been struggling for
years to understand well what does it
mean when that region is is bigger or
smaller or faster or slower and we
haven't had any way to really understand
what that means in terms of the neurons
and so our new finding can allow us to
explain better why the blood flow
responses look the way that they do
just from the sake of brain health it
has to be important that the brain
regulates its blood flow properly you
know if it doesn't do that even in the
short term you might not be able to
respond as quickly you might not be able
to think straight effectively right when
you're really hungry you can't think
straight right but longer-term if your
neurons aren't getting what they need
every time they need it you're going to
start to get neuro degeneration and and
you know we have a population of elderly
people who are getting dementia and
Alzheimer's and a lot of diseases which
now people are realizing more and more
might involve the vasculature and I
think it's just an oversight not to look
at it and think of it as a really
important part of the way the brain
works so really the main theme of my
work right now is that blood flow
regulation in the brain is really
important for brain health and it might
be more common than we think that this
regulation gets damaged in some way so
we think this is a way to better
understand the sort of neural
consequences of systemic diseases things
like cardiovascular disease and diabetes
and maybe point to maybe points to new
ways in which those disorders could be
treated so I'm very excited to be
involved with the new Zuckerman
Institute for mine brain it's going to
be a fabulous environment that brings
together really multidisciplinary
investigators I'm excited to bring my
optical imaging tools because I think
that they're going to be really valuable
in all different areas of NIR
and it's gonna be great to be able to
you know set them up and invite people
in and help them to develop them for all
sorts of different purposes